همم
[موسيقى]
يُقال أن قطر ألياف التوت يبلغ 0.02 مم ، ويمكننا وضعها على الصفيحة.
انه فقط
أعتقد أنه أنحف ورق ياباني في العالم
أنا
أربعة أيام
اسمي تشينزي هيروشي
استخدام هيكل المادة الخام
أنا أصنع ورقة يابانية خاصة تسمى ورق Tengujo.
يقال أن لها تاريخ لأكثر من ألف عام.
لقد تم تناقل المعرفة اللازمة لصنع هذه الورقة اليابانية الخاصة من جيل إلى جيل.
أولاً ، نشتري المواد الخام من المزارعين الإنشائيين.
نعم نعم نعم
وانظر إلى المكونات المشتراة
[موسيقى]
ثم سحقها إلى قطع رقيقة وسحقها بالماء.
امزج مع نيللي لعمل ورقة
الشعر المنتهي وشفافيته مرتفعان لكن يتشكل بسبب طوله الطويل إلى حد ما
ما يميز الله أنه قوي ومرن.
نظرًا لأنه ورق ياباني رقيق ، فإنه يصبح هشًا حتى في حالة تلفه.
يمكن استخدامها للاستعادة مقابل الاستعادة وحماية المياه العذبة
في المكتبات والمتاحف الوطنية
يمكنك استخدامه على نطاق واسع
المتحف البريطاني مشهور
مثل مكتبة الكونغرس في الولايات المتحدة
المعاهد الوطنية للتراث الثقافي ، متحف طوكيو الوطني
نقوم بمثل هذا التصنيع بشعور من المسؤولية.
من حيث تحدي الأشياء التي لا يستطيع أحد القيام بها
أنا فخور أيضًا بالأشخاص الذين أعمل معهم والذين يتولون هذه الوظيفة.
أعتقد أنها وظيفة